en brasilia ir bolsonaro prometió acabar
la deforestación ilegal pero su gobierno
es responsable de la pérdida de 4000
kilómetros cuadrados de selva amazónica
al año y aumentos mensuales de una tasa
de deforestación de hasta 88 por ciento
desde que asumió en 2019 en ese sentido
no se pronunció hay compromiso real de
brasil y lo mismo le pregunto para
ecuador que anunció más protección para
galápagos que ya era un área protegida
qué tal buenas tardes angela vamos a
ponerlo al revés del problema no es que
se comprometan a poquito sino que sería
peor que no se comprometieran a nada
aquí la lógica por supuesto es que
brasil tiene una de las reservas de
carbón más amplias del planeta que está
en la selva amazónica y por supuesto que
es importante que se cuide y se proteja
la cuestión de ecuador por supuesto es
una cuestión novedosa porque además está
buscando la manera de financiar por así
decirlo la protección de sus reservas
naturales cosa que no es nueva porque
además entre si tenemos el fondo
amazonía que fue establecido hace ya
bastantes años por ahí del año del 2009
2010 y esto es digamos una un cierto
proceso de avance
sin embargo por supuesto ante la
emergencia climática pareciera ser
insuficiente
se conoció además hace poco el primer
acuerdo que sale de esta con 26 el de
detener la deforestación para el 2030 un
pacto que involucraba a más de 100
líderes mundiales y que incluye 19 mil
millones de dólares en fondos de
privados para que se protejan y
restauran los bosques del mundo cuál es
su opinión sobre este primer paso
pues a mí me parece una preocupación
significativa porque el hecho de que se
esté hablando de que vamos a generar
inversión oa contratar inversiones que
no sean necesariamente fondos
multilaterales que tienen la ventaja de
que son recursos que pueden digamos a
abonarse a saldo perdido pues la
desventaja de hacerlo por recursos
internacionales que vengan del sector
privado por cuestión de adquisición de
deuda pública pues significa exactamente
eso es decir los países del sur global
pareciera ser que nos tenemos que
endeudar para arreglar un problema del
cual somos más víctimas que responsables
pero otra vez insisto hay ventajas en
esto es decir peor seguía que no se
comprometieran a nada no claro pero el
problema es si no es suficiente y ahí me
voy para el siguiente tema que es india
se compromete por primera vez con una
fecha de emisión cero de carbono y es el
2070 pero eso está lejísimos de las
necesidades de reducciones de emisiones
para evitar la catástrofe climática en
la que tanto ha insistido
esta cumbre tiene valor ese anuncio
vamos a ponerlo al revés la ventaja de
que india se comprometa por primera
ocasión así como también en su caso lo
hizo china al prometer este proceso de
descarbonización para el año del 2060
pareciera ser que es tarde pero el
problema no es que son solamente la
india o sea china sino que todo para
todo el mundo vamos tarde es decir ante
la cuestión de la emergencia climática
el planeta va porque lo que se
supone que va a suceder con cambio
climático en digamos 10 20 años pues no
lo sabemos apenas de ayer lo sabemos
desde hace por lo menos 20 30 años atrás
entonces la comunidad internacional los
países los gobiernos las empresas pues
vamos tarde el problema es ese es que
todos vamos tarde y la ventaja sería que
la india se comprometa que no hagan el
2070 pero en efecto el hecho de que lo
haga en el 2070 es porque está buscando
no comprometer su desarrollo económico
como cualquier país lo tiene que hacer
pero el problema son las condiciones en
las cuales vamos a dejar el planeta para
los lo para ver si que para los chamacos
que están en el camino